un service d'urgence trois blocs
opératoires sept chirurgiens l'hôpital
privé de trappes s'est spécialisé dans
la main mais se place premier en ile de
france en nombre d'urgences opéré de la
main et de l'avant bras en 2015 ils ont
réalisé plus de cinq mille interventions
un très grand bassa l'attraction qui va
loin jusqu à chartres dreux rambouillet
donc ça dépasse des yvelines
nous sommes un centre d expertise qui
est reconnu sur l'ensemble de la france
parce que nous sommes régulièrement
classé dans les dix à quinze premiers
centres de la main de france et nous
sommes en général le premier ou le
deuxième centre d'urgences de la main
pour l'île de france
en 2007 la fédération des services
d'urgence me décerne à l'hôpital de
trappes lé label sos mains qui atteste
de l' expertise du centre frédéric
lefebvre en campagne pour les primaires
des républicains s'est rendu sur place
ce lundi pour rencontrer les équipes
je voulais d'abord me rends compte sur
place de de l'efficacité de ce qui a été
mis en place notamment la coopération ce
qui est très rare entre le public et le
privé et le fait qu'on se soit placée du
côté du patient pour construire un
système d'une grande efficacité
la chirurgie de la main sos mains et
tout ce qui a été entrepris ici à
l'hôpital de trappes
doit servir d'exemple plus globalement
pour réformer le système
ce grand chirurgien a créé cette
structure en 2003 aucun service
spécialisé dans la main n'existait alors
dans les yvelines
aujourd'hui il fonctionne 7 jours sur 7
24 heures sur 24